hey guys welcome to episode 31 of my
1hour flipping challenge today I'm going
to be starting with 50 mil uh flipping
with no restrictions what we're looking
for today is a good combination of some
good high volume flips as well as some
more valuable uh slower flips I no
really idea on what I'm planning on
doing but we're going to have G track
rope we're going to look through the
high volume tab as well as the highest
margin and yeah see what we come up with
all right hope you enjoy and let's get
started okay guys we're ready to get
started uh so once again we're just
going to be doing a 50 mil start no
restrictions um going into this without
really looking at any items I feel like
I get the most authentic uh episode if I
just don't really think about too much
what I'm going to do don't plan too much
ahead of time uh so yeah let's go ahead
and start the timer so I lied a little
bit I did look at one item but literally
just one and that is the Rune Dart I can
see the margin there looks really good
now the Rune Dart if we have it open on
G tracker here
okay so we have the graph open here and
we can see that uh well 9,000 traded
then zero 4,000 I mean there's
definitely some being traded right now
one53
into one25 yeah that's really good uh
we'll do 10k of these that'll be a fair
amount of money let's just do 8K
actually uh so the diamond bolt e has a
7 GP margin on it which is good we'll
do H yeah we'll do like 10,000 of these
you should I think 10K should be good
again you can check the limit on G
tracker if I open it up uh I should have
access to it which I think is 10K it's
actually 12K but we'll just keep it at
this for now now I think I'm going to do
one more high volume item and then
switch over to one that is a bit slower
okay the death run looks pretty decent
as well
336 my God 336 into 352 or something
like that and we'll do the pretty much
the full bind limit here and just take
off a bit and now we have three high
volume items and they do seem to be
coming through Rune darts got four under
those Diamond bolts 300 of those and
death run should come through pretty
soon now we're going to move on to a
slower item I was kind of thinking the
dragon short sword cuz I haven't flipped
that in a while but let's have a look uh
so what I'm going to do is set a 20,000
or 20 mil
limit but I also want to hit a buying
quantity Max or I want to have at least
a minimum amount trade per hour so we're
going to set a minimum of five and a
selling quantity minimum of five and
we'll save that filter and see what
comes up up okay so the Zaraki and spear
a lot trade per hour looks pretty good
six mil item is I'd say pretty good
let's have a look at this now we have an
option we can either price check this
which might be the correct call because
of how many are traded if we look down
at the day graph I
mean oh yeah there's tons of these
traded this is 10 minutes so I think
we're going to price check this now it's
a good thing to have a notepad open here
in case you forget to buy and limit so
we bought for
6750 and we're going to sell it
for 6 695 uh so we'll go ahead and put
an offer in for four of these I guess
they should come through very quickly
okay you can see we already have one
coming through uh very quick item which
is nice and sell for
6749 so once we've sold uh at least one
of these be broken even and we want to
flip hopefully the entire buy limit
which on the Zaraki and spear is eight
and next up I want to try the Dragon
Sword it's a nice mid price item it's
about 1.4 mil uh so we'll go ahead and
check the item it looks like we already
sold the zamari spear which is awesome
uh dragon sword going to price check
this manually as well
1484 I remember when I bought one of
these for like 25 mil into 1445 that's
pretty good as well uh but I guess we
don't need to invest all of it at once
uh we'll do four because they're not
going to come through that quickly and
leaves us with 1.2 mil left over uh
we'll take the money here so we broke
even on that item already and looks like
we just bought another one which is
awesome looking to make another 55k on
this one uh so another flip that worked
pretty well on my last episode was
sharks actually uh so 942 into 951 it's
not great but that's what we have right
now so we'll do 5K
sharks and that would be a nice 80k
something once we process them all uh
death runes pretty much all come through
we'll just cancel this out to get our
money back quicker uh Diamond bolts are
all through and we're going to sell
these off for 456 and we're going to net
a profit of 50k on these as well Unholy
blessing we'll just price check it
into 145 that's very good actually we'll
go put an offer in for that and we'll do
five of these for now okay so we're
going to take a hit on these Ami and
Spears unfortunately we dropped them
down to 6666 and they finally started to
sell uh so it was a bit of a mistake to
sell it for that high of a price but we
probably only lose 50 or 60k on this in
total which isn't great but that's okay
uh Rune darts have come through and
we'll see if we can actually sell them
off for a good profit still 1061 and we
bought them for 1026 that is looking
very
nice one Z why did we only buy 8,000 of
these again anyway
8481 and we bought them for 8208 that is
very nice uh we should buy the extra 3K
of those if we get the chance okay so
we're just going P the Sharks for now
because they're coming through pretty
slowly
relatively and we'll sell these off and
see if we can actually profit very much
from them uh looks like they're selling
for
951 uh which is nice pop those in there
951 and that's going to be 3.8 mil there
uh and we bought them all
for 3824 and we're selling them for 3858
so not a huge profit there now we did
set off the zamari and Spears took a hit
there unfortunately but once again the
the battle stabs are looking very nice
30 GP doesn't seem like a lot but for
how quickly you can buy these things I'd
say it's worth it and we're going to put
the offer in for blood ruins it's just
an easy 50k and I would do this every
time you get the chance now the battle
stabs can't got 200 right away and then
stopped so this is a very contested item
unfortunately but we'll see if we can
flip it okay all the sharks have sold
off we did not profit a lot there but
not bad now the battle stabs are looking
good every 1,000 we flip here is going
to
be uh let's see here 45k in profit uh
which is really nice the diamond bolts
have sold off uh we're profiting 50k
there I believe uh blood runes we messed
up and did not actually leave one extra
to check the limit later but they came
through relatively quickly and we'll
sell them off for 288 hopefully okay I
think we're going to try another high
volume item just to keep things a little
diverse 2945 for the rims uh rope top
into 27
50 oh my Lord I hope I didn't mess this
up
again oh my God it's a really good
margin
but I just feel like that might not be
right although G tracker seems to be a
little bit off today it says 29 is what
I bought it for I guess it's not
terribly off but still uh that's a huge
margin I really hope we can actually get
this otherwise we just lost uh 200k uh
but it happens sometimes kind of why the
price checking that's isn't always the
best okay we got a first rims Rob top
please for anything that is good in this
world I hope it sells for 2943 I just
want to sell the one at least so we
don't lose any money on this flip good
news everybody we have uh a a rooms robe
top coming through uh so we broke even
on that which is great uh the Dragon
Sword uh we actually ended up buying now
1451 this is a long time ago we put that
in there uh let's try selling it for
1501 not a huge profit there but it's
pretty slow item so I don't think I'm
going to invest too much in there and we
have another rims rope top con through
actually uh so we'll pop that through
again for
2943 that's a very good margin I really
hope we can actually flip more of
these and the Rune darts finally sold
all off for
8481 okay now we have a quite a bit of
money to work with magic logs look
pretty good
1051 into 106 70 I think I'm prepared
just to do the full 10K buy Lim on this
one I think it's 10K at least for magic
logs and another offer we have come
through is the death Rune or blood Rune
sorry 288 and we bought them for 283 so
50k profit on that not bad okay now the
money's rolling we got another a rims R
Top flip that is insane 200k there and
we got another one coming through
definitely going to put another offering
of these
2751 we'll put another offering for
three of these easily and we're selling
us off for
2943 I don't think I've actually gotten
the margin this good in a bears item in
a long time orever maybe I don't know I
swear to God 3 seconds later I have
another sale and two more bot this is
crazy pop this in for
2943 see this is when flipping is at its
best that was instantly 400k in profit
like just like that another item set I
might try is the guthan's armor set now
the DX one does work pretty well but it
uh
tends to be even more contested in this
one so
4810 and well that's okay okay whatever
we'll do it um just because it's so
quick we'll do three of these and the
rims R Top another one sold for
2943 and it's another 200k in profit I
can't believe it okay so the rims Rob
top has sold off another one for 2943 we
haven't bought another one uh yet but I
mean still that's great we got how many
flips we get here two sold
and three one sold four
sold five sold I'm not sure if that a
price check either 800k or possibly a
mil from this item which is exceedingly
good uh the guthan's armor set hasn't
come through at all so I think I'm just
going to pull that out and focus on
another item okay I think we might do
the dragon dagger
p++ uh it only has a limit of 70 on it
so it's not extremely high uh but it's
not going to be a huge investment here
so let's do 65 that's just not 1.4 mil
okay I think we're going to do the
battle stabs again sometimes you have to
wait it out but it's back to a 40 GP
margin which is great the one thing I
really like about the Battle stabs is
the fact that they trade so quick and
you can get a not a great return but you
can invest a lot of money and flip it
around really quickly so 30 mil even if
I'm getting a pretty bad margin on the
item relatively uh it just trades so
quickly that I can buy 3500 in like 5
minutes sometimes flip them for 40gp
profit and 3500 well times 40 is going
to be 140k in just minutes which is
awesome this why I like that item okay
so we lowered down the dragon sword and
sold it for
1475 I don't think we got a huge margin
on it I think we bought for 1450 so only
25k there but still it all adds up uh
battle stabs are going really nice again
40 GP on each one and got those sold off
already and we'll pop another 900 in
there to sell I normally would like to
let the entire offer come through and
then sell it but since uh the battle
stabs fluctuate so quickly it just
better off to sell them as quickly as I
can or else I won't get a margin on it
at all okay another nice easy flip is
the RAR seed I've done a lot but it
doesn't take away from how easy and good
it is uh limits
200 uh 7 mil invested you can sometimes
get a 1K margin on uh the seed which
Nets you 200k on a pretty quick and easy
flip okay something really weird is
going on here so the granite mall is 32
into
50k uh which I think we're just going to
start putting offering right now
absolutely let's just put one in right
now and put it in for
33501 and we want to do the full buy
limit which is 70 now the weird thing is
that margin is insanely huge 18K and if
we look at the amount traded per day I
mean there's tons I don't do this item
very much at all
but I mean that's in 10 20 minutes
there's 30 40 of these traded uh and
that's just such a huge margin I'm a
little confused if we're going to get
that or not either way we'll give it a
shot um some things I'm going to change
out here is Battle stabs going to flip
those in there for
8868 okay so um we're going to have to
switch a couple offers around because we
only have 15 minutes left now the
granite mall I just feel like it can't
have a 50k
margin or an 18K margin that would just
be ridiculous but it does I just wasted
a bit more money that's okay going to
sell these off for
$49.99 that is crazy 18K in each one
that right there is like 200k on these
Granite malls uh the dragon daggers
we're going to pull out because they
have only half bought and it's been
quite a while dragon dagger p+ plus
23500 okay we'll pop those in there okay
same thing for the renar seeds have not
boughten anymore at this point uh which
in some respects is good because it
means the price has either stayed the
same or gone up and yeah so we'll sell
those for
36244 okay so I just rechecked the
granite Mall because I just couldn't
believe it and it did drop down to
34490 but we did manage to sell five of
these still so we've still got you know
decent price on those uh and we're going
to go ahead and sell these off but I
think we're going to pull out this offer
just because we only have about 10
minutes left and we're kind of running
out of time so
33501 is what we bought them for we
going to sell them for
34490 still pretty good actually for
this item
3490 and a couple alers have come
through which is nice magic logs didn't
make much on those battle stabs uh still
probably got a 30 GP margin on the rest
of this which is about 50 to 60k and we
have some more items selling off uh so
the only item that I feel like I can
flip quickly enough is Battle stabs and
they still actually have a
uh 40 GP margin on them which is awesome
I don't know when we're going to hit the
limit but well we haven't hit it yet so
we'll try another 4K it's going to be
roughly the limit cuz I think we did 3K
another 3K so that might be too much but
still if we hit the limit it's not a big
deal okay we only have uh 7 minutes left
so I think this is when we really have
to start uh selling off our items
luckily the two I thought would be
slowest have actually already almost
come through uh nature runes kind of
stopped halfway so I don't know just
toss in there for fun uh only going to
get a 8K profit on this so not that
great sometimes I don't mess around with
Nunes that much Dragon daggers uh 798
and we bought them
for 750
two not even we didn't make much on that
unfortunately either okay all the
granite malls came through so the rest
of these 21 we got a uh let's see 34 400
34 500 roughly
and we bought them all for 33500 so 1K
margin on the rest of these giving us
21k it's not that great but still a
pretty good item to flip I'd say all
right guys we're down to under a minute
now and uh it looks like we might still
sell off the battle stabs I don't know
maybe not so we might have to dump them
unfortunately now by far the best item
this go around was the rims robe top
locked out super hard on that managed to
well I took a risk 200k was down to
drain at first luckily managed to flip I
think five of them uh nitting us a
profit of 800k so that's going to be at
least half of all our profit next up the
battle stabs are really good and uh we
also had a couple smaller flips which
are good uh we got well
the granite malls would have been really
good if the margin had stayed uh but
they didn't but still I would recommend
Granite malls if you're pretty new to
flipping all right 5 seconds left 3 two
one
okay so we're done and we have to pull
out all the items here we're going to
have to insta sell them which is a bit
of a shame cuz these battle stabs could
end up losing us a little bit of money
here but that's kind of the way the game
works so we'll go ahead and insta sell
them please don't lose too much what do
we sell them for 811 that's not bad
that's what we bought them for and the
RAR seeds off as
well okay guys so for 1 hour of flipping
from a 50 mil start no restrictions this
time time it looks like we
made 1.4 mil uh which I'm really happy
with actually thought it was going to be
a little bit more because of how much we
got off of the initial uh Boost from
those rims rope tops but we did lose a
bit of money along the line as well but
still 1.4 million and hour is not too
shabby and yeah so hope you guys enjoyed
the video if you want to see more kind
of just um from a higher cash stack
amount definitely leave a like on the
video and I will see you guys in the
next one
[Music]
pap